hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
what we're going to talk about in this
video is how to master negative numbers
adding subtracting multiplying and
dividing now I work with a lot of
students on a daily basis and they're
oftentimes very far along in math but
they're missing some of these
fundamental concepts like how to work
with negative numbers and it holds them
back a little bit and it might be
holding you back as well so let's see if
we can clear this up so that you can not
be so reliant on your calculator to do
some of these simple operations so let's
see if we can get right into it and I'll
show you how to work with these negative
numbers so first thing is let's talk
about adding negative numbers so when
you have a positive number and a
negative number and you add them
together how do you know if it's going
to be positive or negative now you can
see over here I've drawn a little scale
okay like a little balance okay and the
way I think about it is if you're gonna
add a negative number I think about it
over here and a positive number over
here if you have a negative 3 and a
positive 3 you're gonna be completely
perfectly balanced right so they're
actually gonna cancel each other out
it's kind of like if you walk forward
three steps and you walk backwards three
steps you're gonna be right in the same
position negative is like walking
backwards pause is like walking forwards
but say for example you have five
negatives okay and two positives your
scales gonna tip towards the negative
side right because it's heavier there's
more on that side it's kind of like if
you walk backwards five steps but you
only walk forward two steps you're gonna
be further backwards then you were
originally when you first started and
the question is is like how much further
back right so let's look at some
examples I'll show you what I mean so
this first one here we've got three plus
negative seven so you're adding a
positive number and a negative number so
what you can do is you can think about
walking forwards three steps walking
backwards seven steps or you can use my
little scale analogy here of weighing
them okay which one's heavier the pauses
are the negatives well there's more
so it's going to tilt to the negative
side that tells us that our answer is
going to be negative the next question
is is how much more negative how much
heavier right is it well if you just
take seven minus three that's four and
our answer is going to be negative four
now if you want to kind of walk it out
you can you can say I'm gonna walk
forwards three steps and walk backwards
seven steps and you'll see that your
further back four but as you do these
problems over and over again it's good
just to recognize right away I've got a
positive and a negative I have more
negatives
how many more four more so it's a
negative four so here with me so far
hang with me and you'll get it as we do
some more problems the next one we've
got a negative four plus a negative two
so if we go to my scale analogy here
we're stacking up like four bricks on
the negative side and another two bricks
so it's definitely tilting to the
negative side it's all negative actually
right there's nothing to counterbalance
it or to cancel out those negatives it's
like walking backwards four steps plus
another two steps so how far back are
you six steps right so negative six so
that's pretty easy when they're both
negative and you're adding them together
you just add the numbers and it's
negative just like if they're both
positive you add them together and it's
positive the one that gets students is
that when one's a negative and ones
positive sometimes they think oh what do
I do look at which ones bigger that'll
determine the sign if the positive ones
bigger it'll be positive if the negative
ones bigger will be negative then just
subtract the two numbers okay and
that'll give you the difference and
you've got it so in this case the
difference was four it was negative
because we had more negatives let's go
on to subtraction now subtraction in
addition are really the same thing okay
what do you mean right
what do you mean Mario how come they're
the same thing well what you want to do
when you subtract is you want to change
it to an addition problem the way you do
that is like this subtraction is like
adding the opposite okay now if you
don't believe me just take something
very simple like a zero minus seven so
if you have nothing right okay and you
take away seven that's gonna put you
into the negative range right okay it's
like spending seven dollars you don't
have you go seven dollars into debt
right but you can quickly see that
that's the same thing as
adding the opposite we have zero plus
negative seven zero is really nothing
and you end up with negative seven you
get the same exact result so what we're
gonna do here in this video is just to
think about subtraction as adding the
opposite so all you do is you just
change this subtraction sign to addition
and you just change the number that
you're subtracting in that sign to the
opposite so if it's negative you make it
positive if it's positive you make it
negative you just make it the opposite
you don't change this sign though just
the second number now we're back to what
we were talking about originally we have
a negative and a positive right and we
say which one's gonna win this
tug-of-war right okay well the positive
one there's more on the positive side
than on the negative side the positives
are going to win out why they've got two
more people on their side right so this
is going to be a positive two okay if
this one was larger the answer would be
negative and all you have to do is
subtract you say eight minus six -
that's the difference it's positive -
because we have more on the positive
side if you had exactly negative 6 and
positive six they're gonna cancel
another out that's going to be zero
let's do another example negative ten
minus five from now on we're not going
to think about subtraction we're just
going to think about addition because
subtraction addition they're really very
similar operations subtractions like
adding it's not opposite ok now we're
back to a familiar terra-tory right
we've got a negative and a negative
we're adding them together it's just
like if you walk backwards ten steps and
another five steps backwards how far
backwards are you negative 15 steps okay
so with me so far okay let's switch
gears now let's go over to Mall playing
and dividing now there's good news
okay multiplying and dividing the rules
are the same so it reduces down what we
have to remember right and let's just go
over the rules real quick here so if you
have a positive times a positive you get
a positive that's what we learned a long
time ago we don't have a trip any
trouble with that right if you have a
negative times a negative those become a
positive okay so a negative times a
negative is a positive but when you have
one negative in one positive or a
positive and a negative it doesn't
matter the order but ones
once positive you're gonna get a
negative so mainly these are probably
the two new ones for you right is that
when you have two negatives you get a
positive or one positive one negative
you get a negative it's the same thing
with dividing so if I was to change this
into a division problem a negative
divided by a negative it's a positive
and if one's negative and ones positive
we're dividing we get a negative so
let's look at some examples and I'll
show you what I mean so over here we
have a negative 4 times a negative 8 we
know 4 times 8 is 32 okay from
memorizing our multiplication facts but
a negative times a negative gives us a
positive 32 over here we have a negative
6 times a positive 2 ones negative ones
positive so we're gonna get a negative
so that's negative 12 6 times 2 12 and
then this last one we've got a negative
144 divided by 12 negative divided by a
positive is a negative and 144 divided
by 12 is 12 so we get negative 12 for
most students multiplying and dividing
is very easy because the rules are very
simple you just have to say okay 2
negatives I get a positive 1 negative 1
positive I get a negative and it's just
easy whether you're multiplying dividing
the same rules but what kind of confuses
students is when they switch back and
forth from multiplying dividing to
adding and subtracting the rules are
different so what I suggest doing is try
to simplify it by making every
subtraction problem into an addition
problem by adding the opposite so your
changes to addition and you change this
to the opposite just do another example
negative 6 minus 10 that's really like
adding the opposite so it becomes a
negative 10 now we have two negatives
we're going to get a negative if they
were both positive like 6 plus 10 of
course we would get a positive and then
the third case is if one's negative
let's just say like this and ones
positive that's when we have that
balance that's where we have to say like
which one's larger more positives it's
gonna be a positive if we have more
negatives it's going to be a negative
what's the actual number that's where
you take the difference or you subtract
12 - 6 - 6 since we have more positives
the answers gonna be positive if we had
more negatives the answer would be
negative but you're subtracting those
two numbers when one's positive and ones
negative I hope this helps you
understand negative numbers a lot better
subscribe to the channel
I look forward to seeing you in future
videos and I look forward to helping you
boost your score in your math class I'll
talk to you soon